hi this is fresh Hawker in this video  we're going to pose to classic puzzlers  about drawing lines in the first problem  there are nine dots and you need to  connect all of the dots without lifting  your pen you also need to do this with  at most four straight lines and you  cannot retrace any of the lines in the  second puzzle we have six different  boxes labeled a B and C the problem is  to connect all of the boxes that have  the same letter with lines and the lines  cannot intersect and you have to stay  inside of the big box I hope you like  this video you can click through for the  solution or there's a link in the video  description please subscribe to my  channel you can support me on patreon  catch me on my blog mind your decisions  on Twitter at pressure Locker and you  can get my books listed on my website